et le débat a montré sa merci beaucoup
je passe la parole à monsieur marc
fesneau président du groupe modem et à
parrot pour ses explications monsieur le
président madame la ministre madame la
rapporteure simplement vous dire que
votre oncle l'article 9 tel que rédigé
je voudrais simplement dire au collet
qui se sont exprimés cet après midi vous
nous avez dit arguments de ruralité je
voudrais finir par un argument qui me
paraît peut-être ramener tout le monde à
la raison sur cet article
c'est 130000 euros par parlementaire et
quand vous regardez dans la creuse y
aura cent trente mille euros et à paris
il y aura deux millions trois cent
quarante mille euros est donc
fondamentalement c'est bien les
territoires urbains qui profitent le
plus de la réserve parlementaire par un
effet mécanique par un effet mécanique
la deuxième chose vous nous avez dit la
nommer mais il ya 18 parlementaires à
paris et donc c'est bien les territoires
urbains leurs collègues s'il vous plaît
les raisons de ce péno s'exprimer
tranquillement deuxième chose que je
voulais vous dire monsieur jacob cherche
de l'aic laisser monsieur feno
s'exprimer tranquillement et de mon
temps chacun évidemment aura le droit
d'exprimer sa position monsieur jacob
on devait 2e prix m en fait je vous en
prie monsieur ces lots aura le droit
évidemment nous en soucier que nous
étions ou que nous risquions d'être et
vous avec nous d'ailleurs d'une certaine
façon des députés orson moi je vais vous
dire je crois je ne vous sous-estimez
votre propre rôle
si vous croyez que notre rôle c'est
pouvoir d'istres et cent trente mille
euros par an et que c'est à ça qu'on va
juger notre travail je pense qu'on fait
une erreur
et puis là de la dernière chose que je
voudrais dire la dernière chose que je
voulais dire je voudrais vous inviter à
voir la même énergie que celle qu'on a
déployé depuis 5 heures cet après midi
depuis 15h cet après midi parce que je
vais vous dire moi ce que sont les
besoins des territoires c'est de
répondre au défi de la démographie
médicale c'est de répondre au défi la du
haut débit
c'est de répondre aux enjeux d'une
agriculture puissante c'est de répondre
défi des services publics émis
vous ni vos collègues du parti
socialiste n'ont jamais coulée verte
merci beaucoup monsieur fesneau merci
beaucoup
s'il vous plaît chers collègues s'il
vous plaît vous allez avoir la parole
mais nous aimerions avoir un peu de
silence pour prendre les positions
intelligible